القلق الامريكي يبدو مشروعا فالامر تكرر
مع دوله اخرى وهنا نتحدث عن بريطانيا قبل
ايام تم اكتشافه جهازي تتبع صينيا مخفيا
في سياره تابعه للحكومه البريطانيه لندن
قلقه على الامن القومي وكذلك واشنطن التي
بدا خلقها يتزايد اكثر بعد السماح لشركه
اوتو اكس الصينيه باجراء تجارب للسيارات
ذاتيه القياده في شوارع سان فرانسيسكو
السياره الصينيه حالها
مزوده بثمانيه كاميرات محيطات توفر رؤيا
بزاويه 360 درجه لاشارات المرور وعلامات
الاشاره والمنحدرات والحوادث وغيرها من
المعلومات كما تستخدم الشركه الصينيات
تقنيات الليدات التي تخلت عنها تسلم مؤخرا
تستخدم لاكتشاف الضوء وتحديد المدى
ويستخدم هذا النوع من اجهزه الاسعار نبضات
ضوئيه لت معلومات ثلاثيه الابعاد دقيقه
حول محيطها
وتستطيع سيارات ذاتيه القياده الوصول
لمعلومات سائقها وهنتحدث هنا عن تاريخ
وتفاصيل تصفح الانترنت والبريد الالكتروني
والرسائل القصيره الى جانب جهات الاتصال
والعناوين التي تذهب اليها وبصمات اصابعك
او اكتشاف الوجه